les tueurs d'enfants n'ont pas leur
place au Dagestan c'est avec ce slogan
et au crit d'Allah Akbar qu'un avion en
provenance d'Israël a été pris d'assaut
à maratkala capitale de la République à
majorité musulmane du Dagestan dans le
sud de la Russie autour de 19h dimanche
soir des dizaines d'individus ont fait
irruption sur le toit et le tarmac de
l'aéroport de cette ville du caucas
russe obligeant les forces de l'ordre à
intervenir un vol de la compagnie Red
Wings en provenance de VI venait
d'atterrir dans la capitale du Dagestan
et devait redécoller vers Moscou à 21h
mais à l'annonce de l'arrivée d'un vol
en provenance de l'État hébreu une foule
de personnes a forcé les barrières et
enfoncer les portes du terminal
visiblement à la recherche de citoyens
israéliens comme en témoigne des vidéos
diffusé sur
telegram suite à l'intrusion d'inconnu
sur la zone de trafic de l'aéroport de
mahatkala il a été décidé de fermer
temporairement l'aéroport au vol à
l'arrivée et au départ les forces de
l'ordre sont sur sur place au total 60
personnes ont été interpellées et neuf
policiers blessés selon un communiqué du
ministère russe de l'Intérieur au moment
où l'incident était encore en cours
Israël avait appelé la Russie à protéger
tous les citoyens israéliens et tous les
Juifs nombreux dans le pays mais ce
matin le cremmelin pointé du doigt le
rôle déléire des ingérances extérieures
dans ces heures peu avant le chef de la
République du Dagestan Sergey Melikov
avait notamment mis en cause la
responsabilité de la chaîne tégram outre
au Dagestan qui avait lancé un appel à
se rassembler dimanche soir et qui est
soupçonné d'être affilié au service de
renseignement
[Musique]
ukrainien